[Music]
we have a game for you okay okay the
show is this is us so this is me or this
is not me I'm going to say statement you
tell me I like getting dressed up and
hitting the red carpet I mean come on
I literally I think I was I was at
dinner at Dan Baldwin's I think I wore
the exact same thing last weekend so
this this this is not me I ugly cry when
I watch the episodes even though I know
what's gonna happen yeah I mean it's
kind of like right in the middle yes and
no no and yes like so Mandy and I have
this tradition where usually on set Dan
will walk over me like I just I just
finished one oh whatever and we're like
can we when we're done can we go watch
that please and so Mandy and I have this
tradition now we save me watch the
episodes together but she's kind of
funny there's so many moments where we
ladies like look at each other and we're
both crying or she's crying and I'm like
you know supportive or vice versa so
yeah that's alright last one I'm
wondering how you're gonna react to this
I am tired of people asking me how Jack
does I like people's curiosity and I
think it keeps them invested in the show
so I welcome any of the questions about
Jack's death
you